[Music]
[Applause]
come on purse
[Applause]
[Music]
the water will be v-power
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's crazy
are you doing no I just like being water
one place I can think there are travel
Olympian gods big three the brothers
Zeus Poseidon in Hades the children of
these guards were half human half gods
hey mom I thought this school was
supposed to make things better someday
it'll all make sense Percy Jackson We
Need to Talk
just odds
I found her who found me
we've been expecting you the gods are
real my father's Poseidon god of the sea
between myths and legends Zeus is bulked
is the most powerful that were never
created it's been stowed between this
world and the next
if it's not returned by the summer
solstice that will be award our three
heroes all demigods have been harrassing
scourge
and definitely have strong feelings for
you just haven't decided if they're
positive or negative yet we must stand
in fight we'll find the boat
there's no assay from heaven on earth
right now
take this to defend yourself it's a
powerful weapon this is a pen only use
it in times of severe distress this is a
pen
time has run out have you no son of
Poseidon
Percy Jackson and the Olympians the
lightning thief
[Music]